this is sort of related to the North
Korea story that we did at the top of
the show Trump has been bragging on
Twitter about nuclear weapons he took to
Twitter clearly no longer being
contained by new chief of staff John
Kelly and tweeted my first order as
president was to renovate and modernize
our nuclear arsenal it is now far
stronger and more powerful than ever
before first of all how many things have
been the first thing Trump did when he
became president of the United States he
must be like an octopus who had eight
hands and simultaneously signed eight
things the the moment that he was
inaugurated as president of the United
States but this is just so silly you've
been president for seven months there is
no way that you could have greatly
modernized our nuclear weapons in seven
months and I would ask him within the
200 days you've been president what
exactly did you do to our nuclear
arsenal and the truth is he didn't do
anything right he signed an executive
order to look into modernization of our
nuclear arsenal there has been no change
to the American nuclear arsenal and in
fact some of the changes we may see over
the next few years will have nothing to
do with Donald Trump and will actually
have to do with something that Barack
Obama signed with regard to our nuclear
arsenal while he was president I'm not
gonna hold my breath for president Trump
to thank President Obama for having put
that into an into motion it's not even
like a advancements have to make it be
made when it comes to our nuclear
technology to we already have four
thousand weapons stockpiled and just one
of them the most powerful one can kill
like a million and a half people within
the span of 24 hours how much stronger
do we have to get in that regard fire
and fury like the world has never seen
before that statement from Trump about
North Korea yesterday sort of tells us
how much stronger he thinks it needs to
get Trump embodies the opposite of speak
softly and carry a big stick
he's speak loudly and have absolutely no
clue about what sticks are available to
you and confusion about whether sticks
refer to trees or are we talking about
industrial grade lumber he just doesn't
even really have any idea about the
sticks whatsoever it's just speak loudly
if you're Donald Trump people who are
confident in their power
or don't go to Twitter to brag about
weapons particularly 71 year old men who
were already President of the United
States if you're confident in your power
particularly after being elected
president you don't go on social media
and brag about weapons it's pretty
concerning though especially when you
think about last year in August of 2016
he had a meeting with the foreign policy
expert and in the course of an hour-long
meeting he asked him three times why we
can't use nuclear weapons seeming to not
understand the repercussions of that and
the effects of it well this is the same
guy who didn't know what the nuclear
triad was just months ago when you know
you've got your ICBMs the land-based
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
then you've got strategic bombers that
can drop nuclear weapons and then you've
got submarine launched ballistic
missiles total basics right I mean there
are there are twelve year olds who pay
attention in civics class who understand
what the nuclear triad is and Donald
Trump didn't understand what it is and
at this point he's the guy who knows all
about the modernization of nuclear
weapons that debate moment was really
telling because he was a deer in the
headlights there and no one really
capitalized on it all he did was ramble
about how nuclear is so important are we
ready to say at this point Pat that
anyone who either voted for Trump or
continues to defend this delusional
psychopathy is it to be held responsible
for the situation we find ourselves in I
mean kicking can we forgive Trump voters
for putting this man in the Oval Office
given the embarrassment that it is I
don't know I mean Hillary's emails
though I I know I know Hillary would
have started World War 3 because she was
open to the idea of a no-fly zone in
Syria and of course that may trump the
right guy because he would keep us out
of silly conflict that's not the
direction things are going remember
everyone who voted for Trump and
everyone who supported from because 10
years from now assuming were not nuked
into oblivion you can have a lot of
Trump voters denied that they ever voted
for Trump or argue that listen Hillary
was a bad candidate and nobody could
have foreseen the disaster that Donald
Trump would have been we can't allow
them to escape criticism in the future
for having put this megalomaniac into
office we talk about potential
impeachment - sure Mike Pence may be
worse when it comes to economic
in social issues right but Donald Trump
on foreign policy I don't know if you
know you have to weigh the risk and
rewards when it comes to this because a
nuclear holocaust is unlikely but the
the severity of that makes me really
concerned and it's irreversible
a lot of the stuff pence would do if he
was president could be reversible not
all of it but some of it would be do you
think hypothetical thought experiment do
you think Trump might genuinely believe
that doing something to North Korea
might derail Robert Moeller's Russia
investigation do you think somewhere
deep down he thinks maybe I could get
Mulder to go away by bombing North Korea
I think it's more about the public's
attention to it because no one's gonna
be focusing on the Russia story if he's
threatening war with North Korea it's
entirely a distraction but he must know
that that's not going to derail the
investigation he still is going to
investigate what he was assigned to do
counterpoint
if he thought firing James Comey would
make it go away isn't it possible he's
also dumb enough to think bombing North
Korea might make it go away
it seemed to have stifled the
investigation for a little bit they had
to get that special prosecutor in there
that's true who has since impanel to
ground very big big success they're a
grand jury I don't know if I said ground
jury a grand that's tasty ground jury
yeah it's similar it's an alternative to
ground turkey so you could do ground
jury if you want